how was that it was good it was good
definitely we need that one bad too just
losing last game so but definitely great
to get one in here what was coming back
like was it everything you thought it
would be or was it different better
worse uh definitely more than I thought
um yeah it was real loud even we
sprinted out you know to the court it
was loud so you know it felt like a
little home game in the beginning so it
was pretty cool what did you think
during that pregame video cam said it
was he'll always remember what was it
like for you seeing that yeah it was
dope I mean just really appreciative and
uh just being in a moment and just
appreciating everything and my years
here and everything and um just it was
really cool
to how nice was it to come back and not
just play but but get a win and show
that you're doing well in Brooklyn and
you know showing the fans that life goes
on even after you know you get traded uh
yeah no it definitely was good to get a
win um just like I said like our team we
need that one um but yeah just it just
it was fun to be back out here playing
on his court you know in front of fans
they get to see me you know
again um you know was pretty once a year
so just excited to come back and just
play from everybody Cam said it wasn't
that weird playing against Devon because
you guys practiced together for a long
time but when was the last time you that
Devon made you bleed like you
did um
maybe my rookie year I don't remember
but probably my rookie year we had some
battles in practice but um yeah I
already I already I already I knew that
probably that probably was going to
happen maybe I already I know that man
he's hilarious and just plays physical
and aggressive I I already knew as soon
as he got hit when I got hit I was like
of course I'm like I knew it was going
to be him I already knew
it